et même toi Nathalie je te rappelle tu
étais numéro 4 du gouvernement on a fait
du bon travail je regrette seulement
qu'aujourd'hui dans cette manière le
Grenelle de l'environnement
je ne regrette pas ta nomination
je ne suis pas sûr de le refaire mais je
ne regrette pas ta demi-heure
je pense que le premier problème pour
l'efficacité du gouvernement va nous
manger c'est
je veux supprimer et en revanche je veux
annoncer tout de suite très clairement
parce que j'estime que nous avons fait
preuve moi le premier dimanche c'était
les 35 premiers directeurs
d'administration centrale est certain
qu'il partage les objectifs et la vision
de la nouvelle majorité ça changera
est un sujet majeur dans un pays aussi
administré que la France
je pense que Nathalie serait fait une
violence pour m'accompagner encore et
est-ce que le Grenelle de
l'environnement tu l'aurais dénigré de
cette manière
juste près et maintenant je suis le
match de ping-pong entre Nathalie et
Nicolas pour revenir sur cette question
de la pratique et l'efficacité